oh man Oh defeated Sega congratulations
everyone we've done it hey guys what's
up welcome back to potato mo the show we
take greatest-looking games we know and
turn the graphics into mush
my name is Joey I'm joined here by Ben
Jenga hi Joey thanks for having me on
again and in case you haven't noticed we
are playing Yakuza zero I'm so stoked
about this thing yes I know III don't
even mind that I'm playing through the
scheme again it runs and looks so good
on the PC but you're here to ruin that
for me alright now we have it running
ultra settings 1080p look at this this
is his hands on the lights everywhere we
got flippin majima just walking around
sotin buried doing this thing running
into people causing a ruckus people want
to fight me for some reason it's a
really good thing to just enjoy the
setting of yucca zero cuz it's so it's
so authentic it's the reason why I
brought you onto the show is because I
figured you'd be kind of like our guy oh
you want me to take on a wonderful
journey through these streets I need you
to be our Travel Channel host okay
[Music]
[Applause]
that we've seen enough of the game
looking great here I think it's time oh
oh already alright man I'm ready for it
alright let's do it alright so one of my
favorite things here is the render scale
and usually with that in most games it
will decrease the the amount of
resolution that you have so we're going
to 75 you can't turn it off a hundred
percent no unfortunately no we're gonna
go four by three that's how that sounds
dangerous think we're gonna have to it's
the low as we can go okay
is it still is it still recording or we
know we're I think we're good are we
good
this kind of looks like it like a filter
I'm like like a like a PlayStation 1 or
2 game which is kinda interesting I
think we could go this far I think the
disc goes up here a little bit but I
don't know how I feel about that oh
[Music]
there's so much just light happening
take it away Maggio just dance your
heart out you beautiful man I can't see
anything in the background though you
can see that those dancers on the side
if yeah
not looking so hot though I think if
anything this is helping me just focus
on dancing leaving the party already
yeah we got to go yeah we got we got
everything into a potato we got more
stuff to see in more things to do
alright so we have a good number of
Windows here yeah let me let me explain
really quick so over on the right we
have our good old friend in video
profile inspector I'm sure you know what
we're gonna be doing with that basically
taking away all the textures but on the
left side is the the folders for yucca
zero and in each one of these is a
folder for a different character model
so uh we're gonna have some fun with
this I'm picking up what you're putting
down it'll start off with with this guy
right here or we're gonna copy the mesh
file into this folder for majima which
is who we're playing with right now
we're going back in going back in so I'm
making a list of all the things that are
terribly wrong here
yeah I'm trying to process
I don't number one this guy this guy
let's ammaji my ponytail on what looks
to be like a super low res giri but he
has an afro but he gets wait I know who
we are I know who this is
I know this boy who is this this is this
is Bob he gives you all the DLC stuff
that's why he's got the green thing on
his head this is actually a green haired
clown what are you doing to me I can't
see a damn thing ahead of us I don't
have to navigate to the karaoke bar by
heart
man oh I defeated Sega congratulations
everyone we've done it yeah I mean it
drink beforehand yeah I think we all
need a drink
oh I can't see Joey I know you take my
buttons away no either I didn't it was
not my fault
I'm just watching Bob no he's he's
having a great time getting a seizure
from this disco ball madness I'm so
sorry
disco hurt how do we do I don't want to
see it better than I thought that's
almost an F tone-deaf
[Music]
welcome to grave hoppers the show where
we put permadeath into every game you
die in a game you move on to the next oh
my god dude you had no he'll join us
live every Thursday 2:00 p.m. Pacific
don't miss it
what hit me no we're not we're gonna
head on out here and we're gonna see
what else there is to do I say we hit up
the arcade can't be getting it yet to
get it
uh-huh maybe I should just potato mowed
myself every time I do one of these cuz
that was a one shot congratulate I can't
thank you whoo mama you know what Ben I
sad to say I feel like I'm getting a
little bit of a headache yes I think I'm
gonna change the the resolution scaling
back okay normal by at least we'll have
the terrible textures they say it'll
give us a better view of Bob
so we've hit up the disco we've hit up
the karaoke we've gone in and seen some
of the other cool things yeah that's
just what I need and get in a fight I
think you need to get into a fight and
come back and get some ramen well I
think you need to be someone else
someone else yeah I don't think this is
working out too well all right I'm done
feeling it I'm down so we'll go with oh
my goodness oh yeah oh my goodness I
still got the the ponytail on the back I
think that's same with everyone I feel
like we're using Gore or
Mama's a little bit of hander stays
behind with every character we switch to
don't ever forget who you're playing I'm
oh I want to get into fights I want it I
want to go I want to do dancing I want
to do everything I feel reinvigorated
who do you think you are
yeah hi
this is this is more than I could have
ever asked for
this is fantastic I can't play yok is a
the same way anymore
we're gonna save this person do some
bridge fights and we're gonna hit up
pulling darts I think okay you want to
do that yeah let's do that
all right here we go yes hope you now to
swim let's do some some cool bar bar
things don't fight me I already got into
a fight we don't need to fight anymore
we can stop fighting now let's just do
beginner cuz I'm also not very good at
darts
I know it's Goro again he showed up oh
all right so the point is to throw it
into the okay this is fine throw it into
the center this is a okay just kind of
like oh I was one point off of my goal
let's do the pool take me in oh I can't
see what which balls are what are you
kidding me well we got it I think that's
a win for us yeah that's that's it I did
it I went to the one
oh no I I'm pretty sure he actually just
threw up on me Paul our double it so
where is this from
it's yuccas oh man you know usual get a
nice warm bowl of noodles and soup pants
maybe real good
hopefully we'll be able to see it I
can't order any more than just the one
mmm delicious delicious oh come on there
it is you see it right right there it's
just that one block and there's there's
Bob wait wait by the way he's just
hanging out we were just you but now
since we've switched off he's here again
good old Bob it's good to see again it's
me I'm coming in you're not girl
she can't see anyway Goro Goro no I mean
he's not I can't read where did the text
go or do you just go hold on one second
before we fight let me put on my red
dress I need to I need to get into my
fight gear this is not the place for
baseball bats oh my god but it is a
place for dancing yeah
[Music]
hopefully I got the right one I believe
hopefully we Oh No
oh boy Oh No
why does he look somehow worse he's
already naked and has no hair but anyway
here is our good friend mr. libido aka
walking erection oh jeez
recognize them take us away Ben take us
away
what was this out at the karaoke bar I
hope we get into a fight I might I might
take like a little bit of a scenic route
he's trying like who wouldn't want to
fight this guy ah me I would not want to
fight this man I can say that pretty
pretty safely I feel like we have to do
is fight in time at least in beast mode
Oh No look I feel like mr. Looby knows
fight cell is is constantly just beast
mode it's always beast I was always on
never never not beast mode who let this
man into the karaoke bar oh wait a
minute oh wait a minute
oh no oh wait a minute oh no oh wait a
minute we can just do this anyway I
found the button
oh there it is everyone's Idol machi
maguro oh man really bad is much worse
than I expect oh it's beautiful
hey hey hey oh man
I'm kind of upset that it's not mr.
libido but that's fine
bak anytime Oh teeth are all boy yikes I
can't believe I didn't develop the film
quickly the pictures all came out
overexposed we need to make mr. libido
sing I think we do too but man it's not
I don't think we're gonna get the video
with it that's fine this is oh this is
all we need the lights it's all here
the bartender's are completely fine with
this for some reason they're just happy
someone's here karaoke and they're not
sure what to do this man showed up
without any clothes on and demanded he
gets to rock out you know it then yeah
sad to say we I think we were out of
time you know what that's this
understandable you take it you gotta
take a trip to Japan you can't spend all
your time there you've got to head back
eventually yeah I mean thank you so much
for showing us around
Yakuza zero anytime anytime and thank
you guys so much for watching if you
have a game that you want to see this -
yikes I don't know why you'd want this
but if you do put it in the comments
below we'll eventually get to it and we
will see you all next time Oh potato
mode
[Music]
I know you could get a three I didn't
know it was possible it goes that low
yikes let's smile oh I bet you that's a
hundred thousand yen vending machine
judging by the giant text you sure
sorry for the ruckus that that be mr.
whoopee toes catchphrase sorry for the
ruckus the